This should print 13.86, and you might use this process when splitting up a
bill for dinner with friends. In case you're not sure how I got 13.86, let's
just go through this together. There are two items, and we initially set the
cost to zero. So initially, cost is zero. And now for the first item, which is
$1, we're going to say that the tax is $1 times 0.08, so 0.08. And the tip is
$1 times 0.18. And now the cost is going to be updated to be zero. Plus the
item price, plus the tax, plus the tip, which would give us about 1.26. Now,
we're going to go through for the other item, which is $10. So this time, the
tax will be 0.80. The tip will be 1.80. And the cost will be what it was before
plus the item price, plus the tax, plus the tip. Which if you add it all up
should give us 13.86. And if I did my math wrong, maybe that's just proof that
I should be having a computer do this for me.